present the award for best picture
a gentleman who for the past
five years has been among the ten most
popular stars in our industry
a former oregon lumberjack who started
considerably less than
a fistful of dollars dirty harry himself
mr clinton eastwood
i don't know if i should present this
award on behalf of all the cowboys shot
in all the john ford westerns over the
years
i've seen all five nominated pictures
i'm sure most of you have
they were all so excellent and so
different
i'd have a hard time choosing without
one without feeling i'd been unfair to
the others
and so it occurred to me that as
different as they seem
go ahead flip the card man i'm still
here
they they all have something in common
they're all concerned with the human
dilemma and our confrontation with the
fates
human beings engulfed in a lunatic
dictatorship
men brutalized by their fellow men in a
hostile river
families ripping up their old roots and
hoping to plant new ones
and quite different families too who
seek to prove that morality can exist
within immorality
and finally a mother a father
three children and a dog
who ask only to live in the dignity of
which all life is entitled
these are diverse and distinguished
pictures and they are
cabaret and abc pictures production
allied artist sid fuhrer producer
deliverance warner brothers produced by
john bormann
the immigrants a spence film industry
production warner brothers
banked forsland producer
the godfather and albert s ruddy
production paramount albert s ruddy
producer
sounder radnitz mattel productions 20th
century fox robert b redneck's producer
and the winner
albert s ruddy godfather
don't fail me now
okay mom
we're all getting nervous there for a
moment
let me do this quickly in two parts
because i know it's past midnight new
york and some of my relatives want to go
to sleep
there are a number of people i would
like to thank as everyone else would
because they deserve it
bob edmonds for giving more than any
studio head should and time and
creativity
frank your blondes for having the
courage and imagination to sell this
film and make my mother rich
charlie blue dard for having the courage
to finance films which i guess borders
on insanity
and peter bart
who was a friend all the way through
now last thought
there's millions of people who sit out
there and people who love film and want
to make them to look at this and wonder
what it's all about
america needs the motion picture
business
and the motion picture business needs
the united states
good audiences need good films good
films need
good audiences
the american dream and what we all want
for me at least is represented by this
it's there for everybody if we want to
work
dream and try to get it
thank you very much